all right the first big story from
timcast.com brian stelter to leave cnn
reliable sources cancelled
the media analysis show has been on the
air since 1993. i didn't realize that
yeah they they put brian selter on that
show no he has a predecessor um so his
predecessor is a man named howard kurtz
and he eventually left cnn he left
reliable sources to go on to be with fox
who he's still with today but so so
brian stelter is given this show and
then burns it to the ground and destroys
the legacy of a 30 year old show and i
think this whole uh this story for me is
interesting because it's a web you can
see where everyone comes from brian
seltzer he came from the new york times
and then they moved to fox media like
everyone is so interconnected in this
world that like incestuous yes that's a
great word for it media incest yeah and
so to a certain extent i know there's
been some speculation about where he'll
go next uh and that's why i think
companies like ours and platforms like
youtube are so interesting because they
disrupt this uh
member sharing that so you're saying we
should we should hire brian stelter yes
only if i
retain my rank as senior reporter and he
has to start as a junior staffer i
didn't say as a reporter we got some we
got some garbage you want to hang out
with the chickens we got chickens he can
kim can train him i love it i think it's
great look he's you know
i i'm
reluctant often to be so crass in
reference to people but this guy is is
seriously one of the worst in media no
matter what happens he's he always finds
a way into weaseling some kind of shill
defense for the establishment no matter
what they do even going as far as to
tell people not to watch other
propaganda networks only watch us
i get it if you know if you're dependent
on ratings you want to convince
everybody just keep watching us keep
watching us but if you want to be honest
about the idea of spreading truth and
doing journalism then what we say here
is oh you should watch other shows you
should watch the left you should watch
the right you should watch cnn fox news
determine for yourself who you think is
telling the truth and who you can trust
yeah i think a sign of greatness and
confidence is when you you encourage
other people to go experience other
things other than you and then because
they do and they trust you and they find
out that their life is better as a
result then they come back and they want
to hear more from what what else should
i do because you're giving them honest
like you know objective
advice yeah i like the idea that his new
boss came out and and said hey we're
going to get back to telling news
stories and and how can you argue or
debate with that you know he said hey
we're a little bit too political we want
to get back to our origin story which is
telling news which is the right thing
that's what you do you know cnn
really was the top player for news for a
long time and when a story broke
you turned cnn on
and they destroyed that with chris cuomo
with don lemon and to a lesser extent
with brian stelter
they you know chris cuomo faking being
in coveted quarantine is one of the
biggest media scandals of of our
generations of our generation and it's
it's even even ben smith the new york
times called them out like this was
not something they could have just
pretended didn't happen everybody was
bringing up the fact that chris cuomo
pretended to be in quarantine and so
jeff sucker came in
and he turned cnn into a reality tv
he had a personal vendetta against
donald trump he hated the man and so he
nuked an entire legacy how amazing is
that
trump really
i don't know if he broke the minds of
these people or if he like some kind of
wizard pulled it to the front and center
for us to see
but these people's brains shattered when
when donald trump became president
yeah it was the news that i'd leaned on
when i was going through special
operations training special forces
training
when the global war on terror was
initiating with the invasion of iraq and
we were already in afghanistan cnn is
the coverage i depended and leaned on
for accurate information which is crazy
because
you know fighting the war and then being
away from home and not paying attention
to news to come home to that i think in
2016 when i started paying attention
again to the news it's like what what's
going on here it's completely different
world well i used to talk about a couple
years ago the cnn challenge the cnn
challenge was to turn on cnn
and then
uh it was it was to be watching fox news
and then turn on cnn and the challenge
was can you find a time when they're not
talking about trump good luck
and so uh it used to be that i would i
would when i'm doing work i have cnn on
while i'm working and it's for if like
breaking news happens they'll have it
very quickly
and then eventually
uh
something happened with uh it was iran
it was protests or something like that
and they were talking about trump and
then i was like i'm seeing on twitter
something's going on and so i switched
to fox and there it is front center on
fox news protests erupting in iran and i
was like oh wow switch back to cnn and
then i was like what are they doing
there's like major international crisis
happening and they're talking about
trump trump trump's not even relevant to
the news right now like he didn't do
anything they were just talking about
for the sake of talking about him and so
then
something else happened later where
there was like a major flood i can't
remember exactly where and by this at
this point i'm only watching you know
america's newsroom on fox because they
actually were covering news and then i
thought to myself i bet if i turn on cnn
as trump click boom there it is so i
filmed it and i was like here's the
challenge guys like not a literal
challenge but i was like watch
that's all it was
they they destroyed what legacy they had
and reliable sources to hear that it's
been on the air for nearly 30 years and
then brian seltzer burned it to the
ground to the ground and they're
suffering i mean one of the reasons that
i think you probably seem licht like
chris licht who's who's
licked i can't say it i did pop culture
this week and learned i cannot read
anyone's name that's that's that's all i
learned
uh anyways he has taken over and part of
it is to get control of their massive
loss of their bleeding viewership and
their bleeding profits so there's no way
there's no way for it to start i mean
one of the things that i found
interesting when i was researching for
the article was that he has been
monitoring who became more
partisan under during the years that
donald trump was in office and he is it
looks like the reports are that he is
wanting to cut as many people who are
basically
too far
gone there's no way to recover the
reputation of their show
because he thinks that it's more
important to bring them back to a
moderate platform and on our news i
think that cnn's reputation is so
damaged with so many americans that's an
almost impossible task but you know he's
been given this bleeding ship i mean
he's got to try and you know
bail out bail out i'm mixing metaphors
here stop it from sinking somehow it's
bandaged the ship whatever he needs to
do yeah there's there's no way no
there's no submission well what will
they do sell the ip like sell the name
to disney or something or does disney
already already sold it several times
well it's already under warner brothers
right so like it's already a
conglomerate of a conglomerate you know
like it's already mixed in somewhere i
think eventually
uh someone else would maybe overtake
them as like the prime uh
left-leaning
news
outlet which is weird to even have to
say that like we should just have news
but of course we can't uh
what one of the things i found
interesting about seltzer is he
wrote this book about how fox news
thoughtful and trump and whatever else
and then he updated it after january 6
to be like see i told you guys even
worse than ever and now he is the first
one to go i mean he has really
positioned himself as the anti-trump
fact-checking media analyst and uh
his bias is too obvious what's he going
to do what's he going to go now is it
well i heard he's going to come work
here with the chickens yeah yeah well
you know i that's i don't trust him with
my chickens he's got to start a show
like his own show where he just uploads
videos interviews to him i don't know
he copies tim's format like i don't know
what to call them podcasts because
that's like an apple thing apple ipod is
where the podcast
word comes from and i'm tired of it i
don't trust i don't like apple
vodka podcast stealth should start his
own vodcast
people are saying he's going to start
his own podcast
he's going to start uploading uploading
clips to youtube and then his audience
because it's independent media is going
to be very anti-establishment and he's
going to drift further to the right and
then eventually have some flipping
moment where he's like i need to blow
the whistle on cnn jet fuel i feel like
he doesn't melt steel
i feel like he'd have to do the rounds
like you know how we have uh you know
conservatives who may fall out a fallout
of like the establishment they do some
rounds on cnn they take positions there
and they're sort of like a punching bag
for a while i feel like he'd have to do
the opposite he'd have to like get some
i don't think any establishing
conservative media would take him but he
would need to sort of do the rounds and
be like well this is what i meant and
then have this whole redemption arc i
mean i think it would take a lot longer
than people think because he is so
publicly associated with being anti-maga
well cuomo he he founded the ccp did you
guys know that yeah he did the chris
cuomo project correct yeah
he literally called dirty that chris
probably and no one was
idea
like
you should not do that i think tucker
carlson is an example that you can
redeem yourself as because he was kind
of like a partisan hack in 2004-5 he
struck me as when he wore a bow tie i
talked about how great the war was i
mean at least that's what i remember him
being kind of like a a war hawk and then
all of a sudden and it was jon stewart
somebody shocked him awake and he
realized you know what the hell is this
well he talked he talks about it on his
show where he's like i used to think
this you know until
i had a conversation with this person
and then realized how wrong that was and
it took years for him to get back in
people's good graces but with honesty
and integrity and consistency you do i
i'd be willing to bet that if brian
stelter came out in like a month and
said i want to blow the whistle on
everything cnn was doing
the right would accept him in two
seconds and say yes by all means spill
all the beans publish everything and
we'll hear you out i just wonder if he
will though obviously i don't know him
personally but like i think it will be
very hard for him to
to flip like that i think he really sees
himself as this like doer of right
things progressive cause champion of you
know correct journalism i think
it's gonna take longer i mean i think
he's gonna have to hurt financially
before he's willing to give in
it's what's weird to see him do is think
on his own for
in depth because he looks like a it's
like a talking head right so he's
reading the teleprompter he probably
wrote it deliberately and he had this
deliberate approach to everything but to
actually see him free think through
problems and through challenges in
politics that would actually be
entertaining to just listen to see if he
ends up like a tucker carlson i think
he's on the right side of what we're
talking about that's the thing about
stelter he does listen i i see him in
clips in time sometimes like he's being
humbled where he's like oh what have i
done oh god like there's this ted koppel
video i reposted jen perlman tweeted it
out so i retweeted it and ted koppel's
like i mean this is the reason why i
don't remember exactly talking about why
cnn is failing why
why people don't believe you you talk
about trump every day if there's 10 000
deaths in malaysia maybe it'll get a
mention but then it's just about to
trump trump trump and stealth is like
saying
just taking it you know i mean look he's
not really trying that's true yeah what
was he going to say be like well
womp yeah i looked up cnn what it stands
for cable news network well as we all
know cable is done
so as is the c in cnn what's the new
i mean get rid of the name it doesn't
make sense anymore well i you know look
with uh liz cheney on tuesday being
uh
what's what's the right word trying to
be polite you're excised yeah say that
excised yes from the gop that's a it's a
good day and then today when uh i got a
message uh right before this happened
right before it was announced someone
who has got sources hit me up and said
stelter's out here it comes and then i
was like i was like i need more than
this you can't just like dm me and then
i saw like a few minutes later the
breaking reports and i'm like oh man and
then i got i got uh uh word jim acosta
is going to be next so you know i look
forward to it um there's some there's
some positive here thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there